everyone loves the office and one of the
show's milestone events
is jim and pam's wedding taking place
over a double episode in season six
the story of these scranton sweethearts
tying the knot is packed with classic
moments
here are some of our favorites that even
super fans might have forgotten
according to pam the main reason that
she and jim plan to have their wedding
in niagara falls
is to discourage their co-workers from
attending because they would need to
take
personal time off for the long trip it's
a foolproof plan until michael gives the
entire office
friday and monday off on the condition
that they go to the wedding
while this is bad news for pam and jim
it does give viewers some amazing scenes
of the whole crew out of the office and
on the road
for example this is one of the first
times that we see andy genuinely
crushing on aaron
as she sits in the back seat of his car
with kelly he even goes so far as to
confess that she's sweet
cute and smells like his mom meanwhile
in michael's car dwight gets an
unwanted surprise
though god wow oh
i was asleep what no way those glasses
are super dark
early in the storyline michael openly
admits one of the main reasons he's
looking forward to the big event so much
pam and jim's wedding will be the single
best pickup destination
in the history of the universe
unfortunately
this ends up being a sentiment that he
and dwight steer into with full force
as they make various attempts to hook up
with women throughout the episode
while both of the misguided lonely
hearts do eventually find some success
it follows a parade of awkward and
inappropriate attempts at meeting
someone special
before they even leave scranton dwight
meets up with michael to quietly inform
him that he has researched every female
on both sides of the family
admittedly in subpar fashion to help lay
the groundwork for their upcoming
escapades as the pair travel to the
wedding together
dwight also surprises his boss with a cd
he made specifically for michael to play
if he brings someone back to his hotel
room
hello my name is dwight schrute if you
are listening to this you're a lucky
woman
michael has seduced ah to be in your
shoes
against all odds the pair actually
managed to find companionship by the end
of the weekend
dwight with pam's friend isabel and
michael with none other than pam's mom
helene well everyone in the office wants
to look their best at the wedding
there's one co-worker in particular who
tries to step up his game and take his
appearance to the next
level we're talking of course about
everyone's favorite chili expert
and office accountant kevin malone it
all starts with a dramatic toupee
which makes him look younger and boosts
his confidence in the meantime though
kevin suffers a severe wardrobe setback
when he gets to the hotel and puts his
shoes out to be cleaned overnight
rather than being polished he wakes the
next morning to find that they've been
incinerated due to their overpowering
aroma
not one to let a little setback like not
having shoes hold him up
kevin gets inventive and repurposes a
couple tissue boxes to fashion some
experimental footwear
after a long day of dancing and
socializing kevin decides to cool his
aching feet in the hotel's icebox
as he does this he mentions that his
kleenex shoes were a huge conversation
piece he even got some digits i got six
numbers
one more would have been a complete
telephone number
everyone knows and loves that dwight can
be weird at times
actually almost all of the time
nevertheless his quirky behavior reaches
all new levels when he takes part in the
beasley halpert wedding festivities
take for instance how happy he is to
discuss his invention
burger on the go this device is designed
to obtain enough meat
for 6 hamburgers or 12 sliders from a
horse without killing the animal
along with his macabre inventions we
also discover that dwight
is obsessed with twins any kind any
gender
any age his infatuation is deep enough
that he's willing to ditch romantic
pursuits
and drag michael along with him in the
name of observing a magnificent set of
look-alike brothers in the hotel's
restaurant
to top off all of this bizarre behavior
dwight also shows the depths to which he
is willing to sink
in order to besmirch his office rival
and pranking antagonist
jim during the rehearsal dinner for the
wedding dwight is shown as the only
adult at the kid's table
sitting like a king he's busily
explaining to the young guests how jim
ended up getting promoted jim
the bad man was busy kissing the boss
man's butt
that's right it is ew
towards the end of the double episode
everyone arrives at the wedding and
proceeds to wait over an hour for the
happy couple to show up
during this time we learn that jim and
pam are about to get some pretty
interesting gifts
especially from michael and dwight as
michael casually explains
he gives them money every week for doing
their job so he opted for something
more personal it turns out that he
painted a portrait of the couple from
memory
he then admits that he painted an
additional work of art featuring jim and
pam
and i have another one of them in the
nude but that one is for me
we also discover that dwight has gone
full shrewd with his gift
providing a set of turtle boiling pots a
shell hammer
and bibs he also included live turtles
with the present
although one eventually chews its way
out of the box and makes a break for
freedom
weddings are supposed to be joyous
occasions filled with promises to love
and cherish
one item that really shouldn't be
involved is rampant deceit
and yet the niagara episodes are chock
full of misdirection
deception and even straight up lies
first off
there's the fact that the bride and
groom literally ask everyone to avoid
talking about pam's pregnancy
specifically to keep pam's grandmother
mima in the dark
sure the goal is to have meemaw whose
actual name is sylvia
attend the wedding rather than avoid it
due to her old school
morals but it doesn't change the fact
that a wide scale deception is taking
place
then there's the scene where mima finds
out about the baby and michael tries to
convince her not to bail on the wedding
in his desperation to change her mind
michael ends up lying to her about jim
and pam's upcoming addition
they're going to name the baby after you
you know you're going to call it me mom
you mean sylvia yes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the office are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one